The Los Angeles Rams may have taken home the
trophy for winning the 2022 Super Bowl, but
Marvel fans were big winners too, getting
two new trailers for a pair of highly anticipated
Marvel Cinematic Universe projects.
One was a 30-second TV spot for the upcoming
Disney+ show "Moon Knight," giving viewers
a much closer look at the Oscar Isaac-led
superhero project.
But that was just the appetizer.
Marvel Studios served up an entire meal with
a new full-length "Doctor Strange in the Multiverse
of Madness" trailer.
The "Doctor Strange" sequel is directed by
Sam Raimi, whose work on the original "Spider-Man"
trilogy is largely why those three films are
still well regarded among superhero movie
fans.
Benedict Cumberbatch is set to return as the
titular Doctor Strange, and he is joined by
Elizabeth Olsen as Wanda Maximoff, a character
who hasn't been seen in the MCU since the
end of "WandaVision."
The finale of that Disney+ series not only
cemented Wanda's MCU transformation into the
Scarlet Witch, but also shows her starting
to truly explore the limits of her magical
powers.
Since the "Multiverse of Madness" trailer
was released, Marvel fans have dissected it
frame-by-frame for clues and Easter eggs,
and some believe they've found one that may
shed further light on Wanda's true intentions.
When viewers finally catch up with her again,
it looks like the Scarlet Witch may still
be crafting her own intricate, believable
illusions.
In the "Wandavision" finale, Wanda flees to
a remote location where she begins to study
a powerful arcane book known as the Darkhold
in hopes of learning how to control and further
hone her previously unpredictable powers.
Now, fans are getting a much clearer understanding
of the person Wanda has become by the time
"Multiverse of Madness" picks up.
There are two brief moments, in particular,
in the film's second trailer that fans have
picked up on.
The first features Wanda and Doctor Strange
chatting as they stroll through a lush, green
orchard.
Strange, having just dealt with the events
of "Spider-Man: No Way Home," asks,
"What do you know about the multiverse?"
A little later, it seems the two characters
are in the same location, but the scenery
has changed.
Not only does Wanda seem to have swapped out
her regular clothes for her Scarlet Witch
costume, but she is also shown facing Strange
in what appears to be an ominous, overwhelmingly
red environment.
The trailer may want viewers to believe these
two shots come from different scenes in the
movie, but MCU fans seem to think they're
one in the same.
As sleuthing fan LongjumpingTrainer38 pointed
out on Reddit, the framing of these two scenes
is nearly identical, with Wanda seen over
Stephen's shoulder and vice versa.
Also, Stephen Strange appears to be wearing
the same outfit and scarf during both his
normal, pleasant conversation with Wanda and
his slightly more antagonistic interaction
with her in that strange, crimson environment.
In one shot, the trees in Wanda's orchard
are also shown to be in bloom.
In another, they're barren.
If Marvel fans are correct, the most likely
explanation for these two seemingly different
environments is that the lush, green setting
we initially see Wanda and Strange walking
through is an elaborate illusion Wanda has
whipped up to mask her surroundings.
In response to LongjumpingTrainer38's observation
and theory about the two moments, PeterParker72
remarked,
"Very nice catch.
Can't wait to see how this plays out."
At this point in the MCU's timeline, creating
an illusion like the one fans are theorizing
about would be child's play for Wanda.
After all, she successfully hexed an entire
town in "WandaVision."
"I made mistakes, and people were hurt."
Understandably, the possibilities presented
by this theory have also led fans to begin
speculating about the greater implications
of Wanda's reality-warping powers in "Multiverse
of Madness."
Redditor Rich_Acanthisitta_70, for one, wrote,
"I have a feeling she'll be the villain.
At first.
I think it's a feint for a bigger bad in the
second act though."
Redditor Bruhmangoddman commented,
"The MCU deserves its fair share of fallen
heroes and raging psychopaths.
If Wanda manages to be both, I'm all in."
Now, all fans have to do is wait to find out
all the implications of Wanda and Strange's
mysterious conversation in "Multiverse of
Madness," which releases on May 6, 2022.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the Marvel
Cinematic Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.